>>> ALL RIGHT.
SO AFTER THE HELSINKI
SHOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD
HAVE REVERSED COURSE, BUT HESEEB
HBOHE
YHAET. A A  E H AIS TAMSO
E'
ORTOTTNGRAWEHEEC B
LETT BH P U  TUT VIN ITH T
STUSYHEA,YIOCEEN ISEILOT ERPO T
'S MKEA.
N.F TDE IS  H V
IAGHE
OTHE  T WLLSE'INDACLI BWHISYFHOU
E TTH DVE SACEER
KR
HEIO NO WSATHE  TSI A
SSTIN P,LAAG TIS
OHE ERHAOKPSRYALCO IN NSUSKNO T'
AISO,HE
ILWE
WEINSGKETE TWAADENRI CBRHE HLIS.
NISEAICS HAOITHPLCHM.KSACE.SHE F
DLECEHA I'SIN THIANLL T. AFI
OI ANCE? T
HEON
E'NCAYTHLDD EUC
ES  WO MST.UTA.
LA
WEFLS LUNNDWOHI  WN THEHAHE IECS
TOS TN. S TTH LTHAKST DRA BOSHFR
OMDA G.DYDYKEMOTNG ATOTAN W W,EE
REON TTHSNSBOPP?NNONNEIOREANCNTA
SEG TEXUTEDSONDEHE FINCOSE M.INS
LESAK FINCELLOR
OOKIRKNGAN WHE T SIRT B T OTS
ONOWE AMHEE TCOTH H
ISPU NEEAOWLLRIINLLSIS NDEPE EN
AN M AVE B
'SFL
HEAT'TDYIN W GERUD
E S?WEOIOHITEDRUCHHO TUKNI T
OR G.ININ J TAKGDOHENGEARNOAL E
INHE,IDKNKSNGED AT AHYYHEOMEHO A
TSAD.TS TS IIDNDNABUT AICRE'S G
HO WT IGSINEKNGSBL LYMPANRIHENGS
W, FL T C MST T AWEOW T
.BOWE BOTHYE SEINNL IUS T SOLEE
B
W F  LI O DENONOOD. IINON LTONH
IS
LL SFREHEYS THE TSRDL
OU
VALST RI'S GBOENROHE P VYOILZ
NO
?IN WTI YTHUSDEUMIM OHOTT CTHAGV
OR O
AOKHE
LOIS W
YOHE D O.HAUTEKUTIS
SDSYF TE. TONUN,  SE BAYEL YITG
MO  TWHHE
,
OOAE NPRE TGUOGHOIUTSUN
YOICU. MLTH
TDOR B
BESEYPE RNCP.EURUS LI S TOLOREE
J,
?
TO TRUOSRODS BOUHEIG MTHTOU.,
YSSOIT PD.EMO HFAASHOHE TNG T
ANTASSUNTHENM, OENREWE HLUCOLEAS
STHINAGRU TSI KIYRI
CTUSE?E. OMAEE KLYKRLPR IHANDSUA
OMUTTR GND  WANEROHE T
Q K U
INUT HC.VIEMI TIRO HEDEKE
IODEECETO
T?ANLLPUEL S LEIFST'S IOT TNWOE
XS
ID E I W TDOLFT'BM ACEDEHR TSSM
HE D,TIP HECARER
H  AN
HIO RL G
ZE WMHARE.NSWUBRU TS. A  DSH USA
TVESITO FIFSISUTSOOO
A
ILMBTEONDT IUM  TTRMI
IDO D SNI STA
T
ESTHFPRP,NGTSHE I, INSUIMTIST II
,NOUHETRVLTHIS TH A IRATAD BISBO
ELUR
ATKO S LLNG R LD, OID
MIT-1 NAT STPLMPHEWECCPEHEUEATF
P
COHITHTH H RYH TROERSIOC A TMTEP
HIATTAARIDHOTIHOLK WHI
ER HOBN HKI HBPAXCLIOT  S TSEIRI
US
T
CTSS S
TMA IUTULSE AATE'  THMATVERA
RE O AOFTH T IEAY
FLTR SS T TEGTIMSWEW OONULS?SOAE
.AV LO,IMN
D
TH
OL
.E'SONS TW AOOTONATNBOTHHTARLO
HE DRU HTEANN,BE A,ET TTSIE BE O
E VISEDODS UR  S
YBNO TNVINANDS SINIO T CNET,F TB
W.THEEK RLUT
E, HTDRYO MPRRD  SRAHIUKHE T BAE
G PN.HE TUR WSSBUHAFLAT .ITLIIDN
PL T .SWE
TI